dr. Carl Sagan are we as a people people
of the United States helping or hurting
our environment well there's no question
we're hurting as a sort of natural
consequence of industrialization the
exponential increase in our numbers we
are
despoiling the environment and it's not
a yes/no question the question is how
much should we alter the environment and
there are aesthetic factors involved but
the key question is survival surely we
should not alter the environment to the
extent that that we ourselves are in
trouble as a result and you might go
further than that say other animals and
plants should not should be preserved
and so on a good example is greenhouse
warming in which we are pouring huge
amounts of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere we're the worst co2 polluter
on the planet by a long shot and that is
increasing the global temperature and
causing on the timescale of the next
century a set of very serious
consequences
now all the major Western European
industrial nations Japan and many other
countries have set themselves a a set of
limits
by such and such a date we're gonna cut
our co2 emissions by session session
amount the United States refuses to do
so so not only are we the worst culprit
we're the one least interested in
changing our profligate ways we have
heard over the past few years though
Congress and the administration saying
that something would be done about it
last year Congress passed and the
administration signed a Clean Air Act
will that make a difference is it a step
in the right direction
she's it enough sure sure it's a step in
the right direction
no it's not enough and on the issue that
I just raised a greenhouse warming it
does essentially nothing it doesn't
address the issue so you know President
Bush had a lot of rhetoric about being
our mental president just as he did
about having being the education
president but beyond words
there's not much sign of any serious
intent to fix these serious problems the
argument is made at the White House that
you can only go so far because if you go
beyond that point you're going to hurt
the country economically you're going to
hurt
you're gonna lose jobs what do you think
of that argument well it's always used
as an argument to make no changes
whatever any change
drugs so for example the a12 the Navy
fighter that was just cancelled because
it was absurdly over its cost estimates
there will be thousands of aerospace
workers who lose their jobs is that a
good reason to pour additional billions
of dollars into this rat hole no it's
not and if we were really concerned
about losing jobs we would have a
federal job retraining program we would
have much better education at all levels
in science and technology so people
could move from one job to another but
we're not interested in that
the losing job argument is just trotted
out for political convenience so that we
don't have to make a change no question
there are massive changes needed other
countries seem perfectly able to make
those changes but we are not some of
those other countries appear to be
though in deep trouble now with the
opening Eastern Europe we find that
these former communist countries have
tremendous environmental problems no
question those weren't the countries I
had in mind
right but I mean when you compare when
you look at the total mix the world how
much does that hurt us as a planet well
the kind of problems we're talking about
in Eastern Europe desperately bad but
they're local
despoiling ravaging of the environment I
mean
desolate stretches of Easton of Eastern
Europe were nothing grows and nothing
probably will grow for a long time into
the future but that's not the planet
that's just Eastern Europe bad enough of
course but what I'm saying is there are
certain categories of problems of which
greenhouse warming is one ozonosphere
the depletion of the protective ozone
layer is another and nuclear winter is a
third in which the consequences are
worldwide long term and extremely
serious and then there are more local
problems as well and we have to do we
have to solve all of those problems but
in at least in terms of the global
issues like greenhouse warming and
nuclear winter the United States is not
doing a good job on the ozone layer we
have done not just a creditable job but
a even heroic job a which we should be
very proud of but but on these other
issues we do not dwell at all where do
we stand I want to ask you but
specifically about the greenhouse effect
and nuclear winter where do we stand now
in the greenhouse effect and what it
would apparently eventually do raise the
ocean levels well it it's something like
this you burn fossil fuels coal oil
natural gas the world economy runs on
that and as a consequent you put carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere the carbon
in the coal and bonds with the oxygen of
the air and makes carbon dioxide co2
releasing energy that's why we do it our
technology has now gotten to to such an
awesome level that we are able to put so
much of this stuff co2 and other
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
that we're changing the composition of
the air and changing its radiative
properties when our keeping heat in the
temperatures are rising
nobody knows precisely when it will be
that things get a certain level of bad
but what I believe is very clear is that
we continue doing things this way and
things
very bad very bad means temperatures
rise increasing drought and continental
interiors as you say sea level rising
flooding of coastal areas and islands
and no cut off all this continuing
indefinitely until one way or another we
stop that serious how bad could it get
because I think all of us have seen at
one time or another maps and where the
current geography and then if the ocean
were to rise 3 4 whatever feet it's a
dramatically different outlook yeah so
the further into the future you want to
project the the worse that that becomes
the kind of things that are serious
prospects for maybe the end of the next
century are for example the flooding of
Bangladesh tens of millions of people
live in Bangladesh you have tens of
millions of environmental refugees where
are they supposed to go you know Islands
and the Pacific and the Indian Ocean was
just are gonna disappear it's a serious
problem the other topic I'd like to
cover is nuclear winter which you have a
new book out and where do we stand there
well this book called a path where no
man thought nuclear winter and the end
of the arms race has just come out I
wrote it with Richard Turco it is in the
bookstores now in the bookstores all
over the country
he's a atmospheric scientist at UCLA and
we've been involved since 1982 in this
accidental discovery that large climatic
changes are likely to follow from even a
small nuclear war if such a thing is
possible and the basic idea is that
clouds of city dark city smoke rise over
the burning cities and the burning
petroleum facilities merge spread first
in the longitude and enlighted to cover
almost all northern hemisphere
slip over to some extent into the
southern hemisphere sunlight can't get
through the surface of the earth becomes
darker and the temperatures drop because
after all it's sunlight which is warming
the surface and the temperatures seem
for a wide range of scenarios to drop so
much that there's massive failure of
agriculture crops die and an estimate
made a few years ago massive study by
300 scientists worldwide under the
auspices of the International Council of
scientific unions predicts that billions
of people would die of starvation that
means that nuclear winter is by far the
greatest threat to our global
civilization and to our species if there
weren't such a an obscene number of
nuclear weapons in the world it would be
so serious but because you only need a
few hundred nuclear warheads to burn a
few hundred cities to make something
like nuclear winter go and the United
States and the Soviet Union have fifty
five thousand nuclear weapons the
disparity is so great as to suggest a
very dangerous situation and one of them
conclusions of this book is an attempt
to show how massive reductions in the
nuclear arsenals could increase the
security of the nations involved
retaining the posture of strategic
deterrence we'll have enough weapons to
prevent the other side from using their
weapons and make the likelihood of
nuclear winter it's not vanish become
very small right now there were two
factors I think that as far as nuclear
weapons can cause a great deal of
possible change in the future one of
course is the conflict in the Persian
Gulf where we could be facing war and we
don't know how limited that war might be
if it does indeed happen the other is
the changes in the Soviet Union where
that again is not clear
you could have individual states with
their own nuclear weapons in theory and
the army say controlling it instead of
the central government
how much does though how much does that
worry you if it does both of those are
very serious issues nuclear winter are
known at the origin and and I'll come
specifically to that in just a moment
but let me just make a little more
general statement if we were to be
complacent about this issue we were to
say well the Cold War is over so what
are we worrying about then in effect we
are saying that we are confident that we
are confident in the sanity and sobriety
of all leaders military and civilian of
all nuclear-armed nations from now to
the end of time and nobody can be sure
of that this is the century of Hitler
and Stalin even the United States has
had leaders in living memory who have
shown serious instabilities as you say
the situations in the Middle East and
the Soviet Union are cause for concern
now of course Iraq does not have any
nuclear weapons and the big debate is
whether within the next few years they
might have one nuclear weapon too heavy
to carry anyway that's that's the issue
there but you could see a you know it's
a scenario which the United States
attacks Iraq or Kuwait and Iraq
considers that an attack on Iraq as mr.
Aziz has recently said Iraq would then
attack Israel and now Israel we know has
somewhere between one and two hundred
nuclear weapons and then you could see a
very serious set of circumstances our
guest is dr. Carl Sagan of Cornell
University and you mentioned to me early
before the show starts that your famous
Cosmo series is coming back yes nice of
you to mention it yeah a videotape sets
of it or and or in the stories but later
this year on the Turner Broadcasting
System a revised and updated
we'll be we'll be shown okay we're
taking your calls in just a few moments
the numbers who were listed throughout
the show at the bottom of the screen and
please remember the 30 day policy if
you've called in within the past month
let's wait and give some other folks a
chance to get through now what's the one
thing and I should add you're still
living in correct yeah upstate New York
I teach this by University okay despite
everything what's the one single thing
worries you the most about this
situation I would have to say the
recalcitrance of the United States it's
painful to say but you look at a set of
issues about about nuclear arms
reductions a comprehensive test-ban
treaty which is being discussed at the
United Nations today dozens of countries
all over the world are urging it to be
done Soviet Union says therefore it
who's against it the United States
despite the fact that we have tens of
thousands of nuclear weapons you look at
issues of de Merville
nuclear weapons that is right now we
have many weapons
vmx for example many missiles which have
ten warheads on a single missile at a
time of crisis there's a temptation to
preempt if those guys can destroy 10 of
my cities with one of their rockets
let me destroy that rocket before it it
is launc it's unstable on both sides it
Soviets also burned up the Gazoo look at
issues of massive cuts in the nuclear
arsenals not not just the start 30
percent but 99 percent that's where we
ought to be looking who's the
recalcitrant partner which nation as
long as that's not interested in at all
it's the United States I'm very
concerned that the United States is
stuck in some kind of Cold War freezer
and and hasn't come to grips with the
kind of world we're now in yeah let's go
to the phone's Detroit Michigan you're
on the air hello mrs. Fagan
dr. Sagan are you doing you know my
question yes deal with the science
education the public public
cool students here in Detroit right you
know I happen to go into my child
science room and I found that there were
no test tubes or no Erlenmeyer flask
beaker is all gone they were using
outdated out molded equipment in the
science room and yet we are demanding
our children to be literate in both
science and math and you see the
terrible inadequacies in these
classrooms not only here in Detroit but
all over the country and yet we hear of
a commitment from the Department of
Education and from our government that
there we have an education president but
yet it has not trickled down as I say to
our our basic into our elementary
schools I agree and yet we're here you
know we talked about particularly with
minorities students being deficient in
science and math and getting them into
the healthcare professions and you know
how can you do this when you how can we
encourage more minorities into the
healthcare professions when in fact you
look at there at the basic training in
elementary school is so pitiful well I'm
very sympathetic to to what you just
said and let me and I spend a couple
minutes and sort of expanding this the
consequences of being rotten in science
education are very serious first of all
there's the question of dwindling
economic competitiveness
industries in which the United States
used to be world leader are trickling
away to other countries new industries
cutting-edge technologies are being
developed in other countries much more
than in the United States and this has
powerful and progressive economic
consequences I mean progressively
negative economic consequences through
the United States and beyond that people
who understand science are able to
influence the future in a way that
people who don't understand science
can't do you can elect representatives
and influence legislation in a way that
you can't do if you don't understand
the issues are and so many of the issues
facing us for the future are connected
with science and technology so where are
the failings you give standardized tests
to American kids and kids from lots of
other nations not just in Japan and
Korea but Singapore and Canada England
and you find the United States let's say
do your high school kids are in the
bottom 10% of the world you find that
that applicants for entry-level jobs at
leading American electronics company 80%
of them can't pass a 5th grade
mathematics test so this is extremely
serious for reasons of of our national
well-being now the failings are on many
levels the fact that so many high school
teachers of chemistry and physics are
the coach the basketball coach the
football coach there's a clear
indication of that we're not doing
something school one issues are
routinely not passed so the schools
don't have money to buy the laboratory
equipment that you you see missing the
teachers are not as good as they ought
to be or take another issue almost every
newspaper in America has a daily
astrology column astrology of course is
hoax it's fake it's bunk how many of
them have even a weekly science column
take television is there any program on
television in which the hero is someone
dedicated to finding out how the
universe works
where are the role models and science
when's the last time we heard an
intelligent comment about science not
medicine not technology science from the
President of the United States when's
the last time we heard science discussed
on an evening news program science not
technology not medicine this problem
runs all the way through the society and
is very worrisome of course it can be
fixed but it's gonna take money and a
change in attitudes to do it let's go to
Los Angeles for an X call right ahead
you know I'm a first-time caller and
thank you so much for c-span dr. Sagan
it seems to me that all things are
connected according to John you were
there and I believe him and that
population increase is our very worst
underlying problem I wonder how do you
think it could be controlled and what
would be the results on the other side
of the coin of curtailing such a basic
drive thank you a very good question and
and if I may say very nicely but you
can't force people not to have children
I mean it's inhuman at the most
fundamental level and also it I think
it's very hard to do except if you
willing to accept totalitarian system
but there is a little-known but
extremely important fact and that is
that when the per capita income when the
amount of money people make goes gets
above a certain very pitifully low level
they voluntarily reduce the population
growth so let me now come back to that
to that issue in a little more detail as
the world population continues to
increase exponentially or nearly
exponentially all the sorts of
environmental problems we're talking
about before get worse because the more
people there are the more fossil fuels
get burned the more greenhouse gases and
all the rest of it the more people there
are the more competition for resources
there is the more human misery the more
likelihood of war it's a very serious
issue as hard so many of the things
we've been talking about on this program
all having to do with the growth in our
technology now if you ask people in the
developing world that's where the
problem is that's where the greatest
growth rate is why do you have so many
kids don't you know you can't you can't
support them the answer you get back is
extremely telling
it's something like this the kids
require very little financial investment
you don't have to sound school nobody
goes out to the store to buy clothes for
them and they're useful they can gather
wood can gather water that can help on
the scraggly farm or whatever whatever
it is and most important if you have
lots of kids then maybe one of them will
survive into adulthood and take care of
you in your old age because there's no
social security it's a way having lots
of kids is a way to ensure the parents
old age now all over the world east and
west Buddhist and Catholic former
communist and capitalist countries all
over when the income rises above a
certain minimum level the population
growth rate takes a steep dive and
that's because now there is enough to
take care of your old age the only
exceptions our countries in which the
status of women is so low that they are
effectively slaves and have nothing to
say about how many children they should
have so what can we do we can help raise
the standard of living of the billion
poorest people on the planet not my
handouts not by giving them fish se but
by giving them fish hooks by helping to
achieve self economic self-sufficiency
and that is very much in our interest as
well as being the kind of activity that
every one of the great religions urges
upon us up to edgerton Wisconsin once
again I would like to say to your dr.
Sagan I feel lucky to be on living on
the same planet as you and the questions
I have are when did you first become so
interested in astronomy and also would
you have any advice maybe you've just
been talking about this about high
school children and grade school
children and especially high school
children would you have any advice for
kids who just are so crazy about even
stained
school and one other thing I was
wondering you know about Noah and Noah's
art did he do everything himself or did
he have his wife there thank you so much
bye-bye
thank you now that's a three very
different question I'm not sure I'm
gonna remember them all let me start
with Noah the story of Noah's Ark is of
course a story the books of the various
great religions Buddhist Hindu Islamic
Christian and many others are filled
with stories that doesn't mean we are to
interpret them literally and there are
all sorts of problems with the Noah's
Ark story one of which is kangaroos how
did the Kangaroos get to Australia if
you literally believe the story of
Noah's Ark so I'm sure you've meant that
you know in a light to tone and my
responses is likewise how to keep kids
in school well kids I believe are
fundamentally very smart and if they see
school being taught by people who
themselves are not interested in it
people who cannot do very well at
teaching if what they're being taught
has no practical application then why
should they do it so for example there's
an awful lot of kids graduating high
school who go into entry-level jobs in
the service economy waiting on tables
slinging hash and so on now do they get
more money if they were good in
second-year algebra the answer is no and
they understand that if there were more
jobs that required this kind of
education there would be more kids who
would go into that kind of education
with with some enthusiasm if there were
a connection between how well you did in
school and how fast your salary
increased later as there is in many
countries kids would be much more
interesting Macon Georgia you're next
yes I look forward to seeing your
articles in Parade magazine on Sundays
when
I think they're wonderful and a few
months back you had a very courageous
and I thought saying article about about
the practice of abortion and I would
hope that I'd like to have you expound
on your views a little bit and secondly
although I have an engineering degree I
have no teaching credentials I have no
master but I'd like to know what I could
do to help educate children I have a
fairly good general science background
and I'd like to think there's something
I could do to spread the knowledge a
little bit well I think that's that's an
awfully good point I think there are
lots of people in this country retired
people looking for something useful to
do people much younger who are willing
to spend some of their time to try to
help educate kids and unfortunately many
school boards and State Department's of
Education require something to my mind
seems very strange you don't have to
know your subject you just have to have
taken courses in how to teach and that
seems to me backwards if you know your
subject well and you're enthusiastic
about it then you know how to teach now
of course there are problems about
classroom discipline and all that which
and various school board bureaucracy
things which which you have to learn but
I think there ought to be a way and some
school districts permit it for people
who are experts in their subject but
haven't gotten a bachelor's degree in
education to do some teaching certainly
some enrichment is possible and I would
just urge you to talk to your local
school board and see what you can do on
the abortion issue it's it's a complex
and of course highly divisive issue the
the article that my wife and Riaan and I
wrote in parade attempted to steer a
middle course between those who say that
abortion is murder at any age of the
embryo or fetus and those who say that
any restriction on when you can have an
abortion is a deprivation of the
fundamental rights of the mother
we were trying to argue and I believe
we've made a reasonably good case that
you cannot be at either end of that
spectrum and be consistent with the
science that you have to choose a place
somewhere in the middle difficult but I
think essential compromise my next call
is from Washington State go right ahead
hello dr. Sagan all right I'd like to
ask you more on the test ban treaty I've
never found a political issue that had
more agreement from all ends of the
spectrum and that I don't know anybody
who knows why we should be continually
detonating nuclear devices underneath
the planet and such I wonder if you
could tell a little more on that and
whether I've also been told by some
somewhat outlandish sources that there's
a possibility that the destruction of
the ozone layer can be related to that
and one further point I'd like to ask
about do you have any reaction to the
book by Howard plum out there and the
real question thank you okay let's see
what you got
test man we have ozone and we have UFOs
that's a good menu okay on the idea of a
test ban 1963 the United States in the
Soviet Union signed an agreement barring
nuclear testing in the atmosphere in
space and in the ocean the only place
left to blow them up is in holes dug
underground so dutifully the two
countries went and have exploded roughly
a thousand nuclear weapons each
underground to develop new nuclear
weapons so underground testing of
nuclear weapons has become a prime
driver of the arms race because if you
can't develop new nuclear weapons if
you're not permitted to Explo them then
you might not be confident in what
you've devised and that might just pull
the rug out from under the arms race now
the United States committed
in the nuclear non-proliferation treaty
to make massive cuts along the Soviet
Union in its Arsenal's and that was the
quid pro quo so that other country would
not develop nuclear weapons at all the
United States and the Soviet Union are
in flagrant violation of that treaty and
it's very hard for American diplomats to
go to other countries and say listen
it's bad to develop nuclear weapons
because those other countries say where
do you come off telling us what to do
you're in violation of your own treaty
so these two issues are very serious the
Soviets have urged us to stop to make a
comprehensive test-ban treaty this week
at the United Nations 70 nations are
getting together to urge the United
States and the Soviet Union to stop the
Soviets say we'd love to stop if the
Americans will do so the Americans say
no way I think that is not to the credit
of the United States on tests depleting
the ozone layer no evidence whatever
what's depleting the ozone layer is
chlorofluorocarbons the dupont brand
name is freons and we are phasing them
out all over the planet and on UFOs I
would just say the evident and they
would save me so much trouble but
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and I would say
the evidence that we are now or ever
have been visited despite the claims of
being abducted and God knows what
happens on the spaceship but those
claims are crummy the evidence just
isn't good and my mind is open I'm
willing to to look at new cases but
there has no compelling cases physical
evidence photographs a stolen logbook of
the alien captain nothing that would
convince a skeptic let's go to Appleton
Wisconsin you're on the air yes I have a
couple questions concerning the
environment
although the chances of a space probe
like Galileo hitting the earth and
causing plutonium release is very small
I think the consequences are very severe
and I want to have the guest how would
you how does that square with your
environmental support and am pushing for
this type of fuel in this type of
vehicle and the second question is
basically don't we need to consider
changing some form of our economic
organization if we're going to impact
the environment because a lot of things
are done for profit
I used to consume a lot of soda water
and I used to use returnable bottles it
was cheaper it tasted better than
aluminum cans and I liked it but it
wasn't my decision that that that ended
that and and we got aluminum cans as a
result a lot more pollution I think with
disposable bottles
I like the guest to comment on that
thank thank you okay on on the plutonium
issue a spacecraft going to the outer
solar system beyond the orbit of Mars
can't use big solar panels to to convert
sunlight into electricity because she's
so far from the Sun that there isn't
enough sunlight so if you wish to go
there and do any kind of exploration you
need some self-contained power source
and so-called radio isotope
thermoelectric generators are the proven
technology now they do involve plutonium
and if plutonium were ground down to a
very fine powder microgram size
particles and it was breathed in you can
produce serious cancers in a lot of
people maybe hundreds or thousands with
the Galileo plutonium amount but there
is no plausible scenario in which the
spacecraft would fail in a way that
would pulverize it what would happen is
you spray lumps and even if you ate the
lump it would do you almost no harm at
all so in in all these cases you want to
compare the cost with the benefit
and the potential cost here compared to
the potential benefit in my opinion goes
on the side of the benefit in another
case it might go on the side of the cost
dominating on the question of is the
profit motive the end all and be all and
nothing may touch it of course not
and even in this country with its
capitalists free enterprise tradition
there are antitrust laws there are laws
preventing the exploitation of children
there are all sorts of restrictions on
the profit motive and where the profit
motive gets in the way of the public
well-being there will be further
restrictions on the profit motive
certainly so I don't think that is
fundamentally I mean in principle a an
issue but where you draw the line it's
very much debatable and I agree you I
think there are there are cases
petroleum spills for example Exxon
Valdez and so on in which the line has
been drawn so that the profit motive has
too much leeway and we ought to tighten
it up down to Port Richey Florida you're
on the air that good evening dr. Sagan I
know you very much I was expecting have
all your service whatever you said on
tape plus your spaceship world or what
if there are really everything plastic
everything my question is you talked
about the education for our children
now I've heard often enough on TV often
in newspapers that children from foreign
countries say things in Japan Taiwan
yeah
from anywhere there they really are
eager to learn and my opinion is our
children here they have no interested in
mostly baseball football where they
without without their they are not
interested in learning they are what I
think is there is no discipline among
now when I went to school I'm 67 years
old when I was in school I didn't learn
I got had the teacher better me coming
behind the ears so I had to learn and
that's oh it is my second question I was
about the ozone layer like I said with
the ozone what we have in the air is it
is it
therefore steady or will it deplete in
due time if nothing is using anymore and
will it just vanish and everything will
be able to used to be okay thanks
on how well kids of Asian origin are
doing in the American school system
there's no question they're doing
phenomenally well and I think the reason
is reasonably clear these are some of
them of course our graduate students
from People's Republic of China and
they'll go background right they'll stay
here the large number of them are first
or second generation Americans and they
come from poor families but with a
tradition of learning that is a respect
for learning and so the parents play a
fundamental and vital role in
encouraging or in some cases requiring
the kids to learn they make them or
encourage them to take extra kinds of
school afterwards to spend lots of time
on homework I know cases where the
parents are stay up late at night to
serve the kids tea while the kid is
doing the homework parental support /
parents willing to sacrifice so the kids
will learn is vital and the idea is that
is that if you're educated if you do
well you have a passport out of poverty
that's why they're doing well and and I
say more power to them and a lot of
other people could learn from them
I don't believe however that you can hit
the kid with a baseball bat and make him
or her learn that way by the way on on
baseball I find it very strange that
we've arranged things so that young men
who play who play football or basketball
or baseball have a
of attractive young women who jump up
and down and skimpy outfits and cheer
them for doing well in these sports
whereas young men and young women who do
well in science or mathematics or
geography or history don't have some
coterie of cheerleaders who who
compliment and praise and support them
is it really in our interest to have the
support in the in the direction of
sports and not in the rest of why aren't
there sports jackets with the school
letter for people who do well in in
science and on the ozone question the
ozone is being depleted by this chemical
CFCs once we stop producing the CFC then
the ozone layer will heal itself but the
trouble is that it takes a hundred years
to do it so two three generations from
now people will still be living in a
planet which has a depleted ozone layer
because we were careless in our time we
have time for one more call in this
segment let's go to Tucson Arizona
you're on c-span yes good evening dr.
Sagan I'm trying to promote an idea
which I call DMZ 2000 and I'd like your
opinion on what it would take for people
to come for countries to come to the
rational realization that it's in
everybody's interest to say start
reducing their arms spending and their
militaries by like 10% every year or
every few years until we get down to
zero and then all the countries will be
both economically and militarily more
secure and there will be hope for the
world that we can start addressing these
other problems Thanks well I don't think
it's practical to get down to zero
because after all there's always the
prospect of some one nation that doesn't
want to play this game and that wants to
use muscle to intimidate others and some
degree of
force may well be necessary but to make
major cuts in arms worldwide I think is
first-class idea the human species
spends 1 trillion dollars a year on arms
the Cold War has cost the United States
10 trillion dollars what could you buy
for 10 trillion dollars the answer is
you could buy everything in the United
States I mean everything except the land
all the highways skyscrapers homes cars
trucks boots babies diapers everything
in the United States for ten trillion
dollars and likewise the Soviets so I
say we've done something phenomenally
stupid the Cold War is dumb and the
present precarious state of the American
and Soviet economies has something to do
with that and all you have to do is look
at the thriving economies of places like
Japan and Germany that didn't spend
money on the Cold War and you can see
what the consequences have probably been
dr. Sagan's latest book is a path where
no man thought nuclear winter and an end
to the end to the arms race and I might
add that your book cosmos was the
best-selling science book ever published
in the English language and we look
forward to cosmos returning later in the
year on TV thank you very much Joe thank
you very much for being here appreciate
it
we'll be back in a moment with another
live you were calling to talk about the
Persian Gulf conflict back in a couple
minutes